we have the story from the New York Post
NBC freelance reporter ripped for
linking Nashville shooting to Ben
Shapiro and the daily wire he deleted it
but Benjamin Ryan tweeted NBC is id'd
the Nashville shooter as Audrey Hale 28
who identifies as transgender and had no
previous criminal record Nashville is
home to the Daily wire a hub of
anti-trans activity by Matt Walsh blog
Ben Shapiro and Michael J Knowles
journalists that's what they call
themselves
they are they look
I just don't see
I think I think a lot of conservatives
think this country is still unified and
they're shocked that journalists would
do these things there was just uh there
was just a thing in the New York Post
about how that patriotism in this
country is the lowest it's been in in
him and his like in the entire history
of this country patriotism and love
country have never been lower but what
I'm saying is I think conservatives
still believe there are rules
they they they think there are rules and
they demand you play by them and these
people are going okay I'll take the
Tweet down I'll just not get caught next
time
so while we keep trying to play this
game of can you believe these
institutions would say to the thing I
demand a retraction they're sitting in
their room laughing being like these
morons are still playing by the rules
while no one else is
also nobody sees the retraction anyways
and and nobody ever a little bit they
make money off it yeah but but in
general you post you post the article
first you get the rage out of it you
retract it later when all of that's
passed through and no you know maybe a
quarter of the people that saw the
initial one see the CVS but it's good
for them
it's all about that but look they put
all kinds of false narratives in even if
they clear it up in the last final fifth
paragraph of it it's so disgusting and
dishonest it's reprehensible to me a
fake article journalist they're
propagandist a fake article will get one
million views and then a week later the
retraction will get another fifty
thousand that's one million 50 000 views
for their bottom line it's all at
Revenue did you say this article got
taken down no no his tweet he deleted it
and they make those and they post those
articles knowing they will likely have
to post a retraction later knowing that
if you're a propagandist you got your
word out there initially sure you have
to retract it later sure maybe a quarter
of the people see that but that's
another you know that's the rest that
did who gets the win exactly
think about what this tweet really means
though of course this reporter is trying
to frame it in a certain way and and
Link them but I'll put it this way if
Ben Shapiro Matt Walsh Michael Knowles
the daily wire are saying this is bad
this is dangerous and we need to do
something about it
and then
a trans person goes and shoots up a
church and school doesn't that prove the
daily wire correct that we need to pay
attention what's going on we need to
help these people and prevent these
tragedies from happening no you shift
The Narrative and make it about gun
control and say that people shouldn't
own guns and then immediately people
forget
but I think the uh the real answer is
yes yes we should it does prove that
there's a big problem right now with
drugging up people I think the gun
control narrative is a useful tool for
Democrats because absolutely it gives
you a never-ending problem something
that can never be solved 3D printed guns
exist and it what ends up happening is
the Democrats come out and they say
we're gonna we're gonna solve this
problem and then they ban some weird
random thing completely unrelated to
anything
then they say we did it did anyone I I
saw someone talking about how there
recently was gun control legislation
just signed by Joe Biden plus we had the
ATF rule did these things matter at all
they're talking about how one of the
weapons the two it was two AR-15s and a
handgun right but I'm pretty sure I
could be wrong you guys in the chat
correct me pretty sure one of the
weapons used by the shooter was an AR
style nine millimeter rifle so is that
it's like a five five six or anything
like that yeah so this salt style rifle
assault style which means nothing right
right and I I it is it is really
annoying how everyone the post
millennial and the New York Post are
calling them assault rifles when they're
not AR style trigger semantics every
single day that's what they do they use
these Buzz words they're like okay we're
gonna trigger everybody with this we're
gonna say it and they know it um you
know words matter and they use these
words to alarm and to stigma you know
stigmatize people and create a whole
panic situation and like 99 of the
people out there that are doing this
whole total hysteria even and Nancy
Pelosi came back from the dead to make a
comment about this and freak Show tales
of the crypt and yeah hey I don't know I
was related there you go my aunt talk
about that
Thanksgiving nice wow you know but you
know but but I I call out the nonsense
you know I don't like people who are
dishonest they don't tell the truth
they're saying something to achieve
their ideological agenda their objective
and they will do it at any cost they
don't care if they're sitting there you
know telling a lie to the public
everything is a disinformation you know
campaign it's massive propaganda and by
the time we figure everything out you're
literally whatever or there's a
retraction or we actually find out like
Twitter files or whatever the damage is
done nothing to see here folks and
nobody see like that's nobody sees it
like I had to tell my dad about the
Twitter files and explain to him like
just how big TV and this happened yeah
like you have to explain to them how big
of a deal something like this is because
and then rated him in most of the
culture whether you know not just
Boomers but a lot of people still they
put that faith in Legacy Media and the
in what they believe to be pure truth or
why would they lie right uh not
understanding that for-profit media like
that has it's baked into the business
model to lie it's a thousand percent but
it's also incentivized because it works
it actually creates profit because they
get people click bait to click on it and
that's it they don't care if they have
to retract it later was it like that no
consequence in the early days way way
worse now when did it shift you know I
like we had kind of mentions before but
like when you went through I think 2016
election because of the whole Trump
derangement syndrome and all the
insanity that people like flipped out
about that
um then we went into 2020 election Shin
everything that transpired there then it
was the lockdowns you know with the
pandemic leading up to 2020 on people
all at home newsrooms change no one was
in the same room like we are right now
today going over stuff and then you had
a lot quite frankly of the young people
out there that were working in some of
these jobs Etc and like a very vocal
minority talking about how this made
them feel or that made them feel or you
know they were upset remember the Tom
Cotton stuff in the New York Times and
the editorial and then like everybody
was rioting at the New York Times saying
we were so disgusted to work for this
news organization how dare you you put
this you know opinion article up that he
had and it became that whole thing and
it really developed the perfect cocktail
the group think and that's what's sort
of taken over it's just like a complete
uh like sort of like a parasite takes
over right you have a host and you take
it over that's what's happened now in
terms of the thinking I just want a
quick reaction while we're still in this
segment people are mentioning it the
weapon used was a Kel-Tec Sub 2000
carbine nine millimeter variant so
important distinction so you're saying
that a lot of this disruption in media
and and I don't know crackery or
whatever you want to call it this
breaking of the narrative is because the
newsrooms are diffused you're no longer
in person working together I think it's
one of the ingredients to the chaos
cocktail where it's like you have that
you had the pandemic people not together
you and and to be quite Frank like just
all the response like Donald Trump and
what he did and being an outsider and
someone coming in that wasn't part of
that political you know establishment
right but to be fair you saw the same
thing they didn't like it they stole it
from you know Bernie Sanders Bernie
Sanders was not party established they
wanted you know Hillary Clinton uh you
know anybody you know but Trump someone
that they could establish so when you
actually see they're very similar the
two sides they mirror each other in the
establishment the way they want to
control people in the way you think and
if you're you're not some of the Beats
of that drummer plays inside that system
you're an agent of chaos and they will
do whatever it takes to destroy you
Bernie bent the knee and shifted his
policy positions I just think there's no
moral character there I think there's no
moral character there he actually stood
and believed in something and then he
showed himself to be you know sort of a
you know a false prophet not someone who
actually stood for his principles and
what he believed in he also you know
essentially let the DNC and everyone
take the you know the nomination from
him and gave it over to Hillary Clinton
or Joe Biden well they had both they had
all the moderates right drop out at the
same time and then endorse Joe and then
surprise it's called collusion they get
offered those cushy jobs right you know
you know what I bet I bet they went to
Buddha and said look we'll make a
transportation we'll give you we'll give
you some do nothing job I don't know
something like Transportation secretary
and then he's like all right works for
me and then uh oh now he's gotta work
that's why he's nowhere to be seen
that's why he's not doing his job right
that's why there's all those train
derailments right yeah probably the
deals were cut but that's exactly how it
works it's establishment whether it's in
left I know I know I spent years being
like a front row seat to you know left
this liberal Democrat agenda even though
I was a republican I guess I was like a
Sleeper Cell in there and then I went on
this side and I see it so I see what the
two extremes are like and what they want
to put together and they're not that
different in terms of wanting to be able
to control the people within the party
they're going to play the party game and
not Buck the system or the establishment
I don't trust either side but that's
what I'm saying I don't trust Fox News
anymore than I trust CNN or MSNBC I'm
not telling you should I'm not sorry it
sounds pretty good yeah
everybody else soccer and I love my my
team on the five I know Greg is good
yeah he's fantastic they're very good
the five is very good except for the
especially one but the five is also in
the weirdos in the early days people
could tell me I was like Juan Williams
no that's a trigger word that's funny
were you on that show yeah
okay Juan Williams don't even get me
started I can't stand the guy but I
really do like that he's on the show
yeah well he they have put him on every
once in a while now he's sort of like
well because you know whatever does the
dude even have Google is my question I
don't know but he doesn't really care
because I would say where are you
getting that what are you saying
um you know and he's like super angry
and just had all this Victory all about
stuff and I was like have you even met
this person do you know what you're
talking about and like look at me in the
eye when you're talking to me so
whatever I liked Bob Beckel Bob Beckel
because he would say and I go Bob what
the hell I go where are you getting that
I go you just made that up he goes yeah
so
hey what do I care you know because he
like ran mondales like he got like once
he won one state he goes and I had to
pay for it wow thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time